we're told that a particle moves along
the curve x squared y squared is equal
to 16 so that the x coordinate is
changing at a constant rate of
of negative two units per minute
what is the rate of change in units per
minute of the particle's y-coordinate
when the particle is at the point 1
comma 4.
so let's just repeat or rewrite what
they told us so the curve is described
by x squared
y squared is equal to 16. they tell us
that up there to tell us that the x
coordinate is changing at a constant
rate let me underline that the x
rate of negative two units per minute so
we could say that dx all right over here
on the right hand side dx
dt the rate of change of the x
coordinate with respect to time is equal
to negative 2 and they're saying units
be subunits
some unit of distance
units divided by minute
units per
minute
and what they want us to figure out is
what is the rate of change of the
particle's y-coordinate so let me
underline that what is the rate of
change of the particle's y coordinates
so what they want us to find is what is
d y
dt what is that equal to and we and they
say when the particle is at the point 1
comma 4. so when x is equal to 1
so x is equal to 1 and y is equal to 4.
y is equal to 4.
so can we set up some equation that
involves the rate of change of x with
respect to t y with respect to t x and y
well what if we were to take the
derivative of this relation that
describes the curve what if we were to
take the derivative with respect to t on
both sides so let me write that down so
we're going to take the derivative
actually let me just let me just let me
just erase
this so i have a little bit more space
all right
and so that way i can just add it
so
let's take the derivative with respect
to t
of both sides of that
and if any point you get inspired i
encourage you to pause the video and try
to work through it
well on the left hand side if we view
this as a product of two functions right
over here we could take the derivative
of
we could take the derivative of the
first function which is going to be
the derivative of x squared with respect
to x so that is
x and remember we're not just taking the
derivative with respect to x we're
taking the derivative with respect to t
so we're going to apply the chain rule
so it's going to be the derivative of x
squared with respect to x which is 2x
times the derivative of x with respect
to t
so times
dx dt
and then we're going to multiply that
times the second function
so times y squared
times y squared and then that's going to
be plus the first function which is just
x
squared times the derivative of the
second function with respect to t and so
once again we're going to apply the
chain rule the derivative of y squared
with respect to y is 2y let me do that
in that orange color
it is equal to
y and then times the derivative of y
with respect to t
times d y
dt
and then that is going to be equal to
that is going to be equal to the
derivative with respect to t of 16 well
that doesn't change over time so that's
just going to be equal to zero and so
here we have it we need we need to
simplify this a little bit but we have
an equation that gives a relationship
between x derivative of x with respect
to t y and derivative of y with respect
to t so actually let me just rewrite it
one more time so it's a little bit
simplified so this is
x y squared
dx dt
it
plus actually i don't even have to
rewrite it again we can all we're doing
trying to do is solve for d y dt so
let's actually just substitute the
values in so we know we want to figure
out what's going on when x is equal to 1
so we know that
the x is here are equal to 1
this x x squared well that's just going
to be 1 squared so that's going to be
equal to 1. we know that y is equal to
4.
so this is going to be 16
and this is going to be
8. we know the derivative of x with
respect to t is negative 2 they tell us
that in the problem statement
negative 2 and so now this is a good
time to simplify this thing
so this will simplify 2
let's see all of this is going to be 2
times 1 times negative 2 so that is
negative 4 times 16 so that is negative
64.
and then we have
and then we have let me do this in a
color you can see
and then we have all of this well this
is just going to be 1 times 8 times d y
dt so this is going to be eight d y d t
so plus eight times the derivative of y
with respect to t is equal to zero add
64 to both sides and we get i'll switch
to a neutral color eight times the
derivative of y with respect to t is
equal to 64. divide both sides
by 8 and you get the derivative of y
with respect to t is equal to 64 divided
by 8 is just 8. and if if you wanna if
you wanna look at the units it will also
be in units per minute
use some units of distance
per
per minute and
we are
done